now this next thing I'm going to tell
you is so important it's the most
important thing that talk about so if
anyone's checked out check back in right
now
do you hear you've heard that obesity is
a health risk right
it causes diabetes heart attack stroke
cancer bad luck right everything right
that's what I was taught too but I found
that's absolutely not true it's a myth
let me explain I had a patient come in
29 years old weighed 325 pounds did my
program this is a long time ago take
awhile guess how much weight she lost in
the first month nope no no no now
exactly it's zero pounds she lost zero
pounds okay now who would be depressed
if you lost zero weight yeah but she was
actually okay with it because she felt
better okay the second month she lost
twenty-one pounds the third month she
lost 63 pounds who was at that point
when I had a lightbulb go off I'm like
wow you don't you don't lose weight and
get healthy you get healthy to lose
weight see I've been doing it the other
way around that changed my whole
practice because now everything that I
aligned was going to get them healthy
and I started to see results on people
that would normally ever get results
it's the health you cannot be fat and
healthy at the same time being healthy
the weight comes off as a natural side
effect
obesity is a symptom of an unhealthy
body not the cause of it why are they
doing that why are they pushing it so
they can come up with the drugs to treat
it again it's a symptom does this make
sense so here's what I want you to do I
want you to change your viewpoint goal
from losing weight to creating more
health go ahead and do it right now go
ahead and just shift make the shift come
on in the back there shift it okay good
so have you decided that you'll create
more health
because that's how you do it forget
about the diets we have to get your
lifestyle corrected
forget about vitamins unless you can get
your eating corrected because
understanding that is a superior
principle that will take you not just to
lose weight but to get younger as you
get older I'm 65 now I'm just kidding
now I'm 47 but I feel like I'm 25 I mean
I wrestled my kids and I and I'm like
I'm working on I'm actually trying to
reverse the aging process and so that's
what I want you guys to do as every year
you get older getting younger but all it
takes is a shift of viewpoint rather
than oh here's the diet you have to
understand what to do so there's three
things I want you to do number one find
out your body type number two get in a
plan that's specific for your body type
and number three stick to it through
creating healthy habits that you can do
long-term so it's all about create your
health every day it has to be built just
like everything else in life I want to
thank you guys for coming I hope you
learn something I appreciate your
attention this long have a great
afternoon